Malik you've helped so many students
along the way here in the United States
win championships get World youth
European World youth medals and finally
you got your own Championship right
medal tell us about your initial
feelings thank you thank you yeah
yesterday I got so many like attacks so
many like messages like thank you
Christian yes I did like help many kids
to win like a world youth World Cadets
like pan amps I mean many many
tournaments but myself I had never won
any national championship
I mean I don't know uh maybe my I'm not
sure what to say and I'm very happy I'm
very relieved and first time ever I I
want I won national championship and
with a big one
I mean it's kind of breakthrough toward
me for myself uh I was hoping for it I
worked hard I changed everything in my
life in recent like what six months or
so diet and physical conditions
chess trainings I
I took many uh I mean not many but few
very strong students that also helped me
a lot uh were working with International
Masters working with grand Masters you
know that Christian it also makes you
being like stronger because you must
follow like you know like your Trends
new ideas everything and um that made me
because I used to be one of my issues
was let's say I was kind of predicted I
would say but then working with a
national team working with ladies with
girls and working with my top students I
start to expand my my openings and
everything I start to get uh just
feeling more comfortable to play
different type of positions so
and it helps me a lot
one of the things that I found very
difficult whenever I'm coming from a
long layover is just getting the dust
off the shoulders did you feel any of
that or you've been playing Sanchez
previous to this tournament as well
right no I mean yeah you're correct
because uh one of my issues because I
don't really Play constantly because I
have no time for that I'm full-time
chess coach and um and that perhaps the
reason why my my rating was kind of uh
um I would say very inconsistent and
dropping because most of the cases I was
let's say facing those really young
talented kids like 2200 range and
I couldn't beat them like every
tournament I play like plus one plus two
whatever it is plus three sometimes but
still losing my rating and uh but um I
always knew uh I'm not let's say 2400
player I always knew I mean I I can't
just I can play chess much better than
this rating
um
so what for this tournament uh as I said
I mean mostly I realized when I started
my games from previous U.S seniors I
realized uh most of my games when I
played against strong players I'm kind
of giving away the points after third
hours like between like four hours close
to the time pressure
so what I start to understand like
what's the reason why I'm doing this uh
I came to a conclusion it's actually
most of my physical condition
because at some point I'm stopping like
absorbing the board properly you know
like my brain gets off
so the first week what I have done like
I said I paid attention to my physicals
I dropped some weight and I started to
working on myself and and I think it's
mostly paid off yeah and you also
mentioned actually at the beginning of
the tournament that he took a completely
different approach to the training for
this one you actually took a vacation
with your family spent some quality time
with them I want to give you the
opportunity to give thanks to your
support system yeah I mean my wife is my
manager for sure yeah I mean she
insisted to go to the vacation and for
my birthday and we again when we plan
the vacation actually we didn't realize
it's going to be like a U.S junior I was
hoping for it because one of my kids
playing here Roy Comanche gave me the
dates I thought okay maybe I'm going to
get this invitation so I managed my
vacation for those dates just in case
just in case no seriously it's true so I
made this vacation and then I was I took
a laptop with me with my files and
everything and she's sitting on no
laptop no files you me kids that's it so
the only chance whatever they were going
to sleep I was I was still going through
some some lines kind of you know a
little bit working for myself there but
mostly you're right this was completely
like shadow of my brain
not a single lesson they said what to do
the first time ever in my life like for
six seven days no single lesson online
none zero so just the kids family my
wife and uh occasion my laptop
for myself they said that this is the
first big uh I made adjustment uh second
big adjustment
um somehow I found a right uh formula
here it worked for me
I used to be doing gym every day or at
least every other day
this time I stopped doing that yeah I
only like was working outside a little
bit
uh like a half an hour or 40 minutes
yeah yeah and then I was trying to pay
attention mostly to sleep what I did
like before the game every time like
half an hour or 40 minutes left now
it actually helps me a lot yeah
because when I was forcing myself to
close all those curtains you know my
internet's just to sleep in in the
darkness uh and that kind of it's kind
of made myself like uh come loosen up a
little bit Yeah so waking up around like
uh 12 15 12 10 quick shower and to the
game so
and it works perfectly so every day it
was perfect for me so look out well you
could also the manager for probably
pointing you out in the right direction
congratulations
U.S Senior Champion guys any question
for our champion Kate yeah
congratulations really fantastic
accomplishment I'm curious you said that
you had like no expectations for this
tournament because in the last one you
did not do very well but can you
pinpoint the moment or the game in this
tournament when you realize like hey
maybe I can actually win this
well yeah
um initially when I came here I was just
trying to have some fun and play game by
game interesting game I still be doing
that but I mean my beliefs
came after round two uh firstly in the
first round I played Wagner copper and
very strong grandmas The Legend and I
always had uh kind of you know difficult
result against him and so when somehow I
predicted the whole thing the opening
and
I was kind of happy because the I knew
everything uh the position and I kind of
had the feelings like Vladimir perhaps
did not expect this line from me
and when I got like a and I also feel
somehow I feel I I have seen more in a
game than Vladimir because he clearly
missed the idea of Queen H3 it clearly
missed the idea of 96. so this made me
like believe I can do this first time
the second time when I uh when I survive
against nobikov yeah I've been a survive
against novika that game was in my
opinion crucial it actually uh started
to make me think okay maybe it's your
tournament maybe you can do it maybe you
can do it and maybe you can you know
push your dices and then
I guess I'll tell you like uh I would
say the final final sort of beliefs came
after the game against mitigure which
when we're usually having very tough
fight against Dmitry and somehow with
black pieces I got easy win
so for me it was uh clearly that it's
kind of sign that is it's my tournament
you know absolutely yeah look at that
beautiful score line Malik once again
congratulations thank you so much thank
you absolutely and turning our attention
now it's